yeah welcome to this video playing Chris
5056 from South Africa this is South
Africa right okay let's play the bank oh
I haven't played this for a long while a
dad didn't have I had pretty pretty
decent results with this opening and
blitz 36 okay he's playing this declined
with be six so quite a decent line not
taking back the porn immediately maybe i
can not sure i don't know the exact
theory here anyway maybe i can somehow
confuse them yeah well the bishop is not
great on b7 but he moved the sponsor
often okay is there some way to make use
of this bishop and probably not like it
6m but this weakens weakens the whole
hood structure far too far too much
night c4 i want to play night be five ok
it allows me to do that surprisingly
night deform I don't we cannot really
take it I mean this would give me an
enormous position and 94 is quite nice
if i take here
rugby hm maybe look the engine why not
it just gives me the spawn I'm not quite
sure what compensation there is yeah
however one one thing is say is my my
bishop here this is just a terrible
piece okay let's let's get it to a six
maybe I lose the a porn but it's it's
simply such a passive piece I mean push
your basics I like that let's get rid of
this this passive peace bishop a six now
I can take be eight then I would serve I
need to take with them take with the
night
yeah maybe why not why not it's a it
still keeps the pawn I mean due to this
pin you cannot take a five look be one
just 97 back
hmm
yeah what you do what do I can I can
also take it now but I think this is
also good try to use it on the kingside
maybe night h5 it's this is nice but
it's got all pieces on the queenside
maybe there's also simply capture all
interesting maybe this one intending
would be eight if you takes Queen takes
I keep I keep my pawn and not Queen a
five I have I can just take I mean I
just briefly thought maybe even see for
as a move but I can take this was the
intention and at the end i get the a
pond or or end to the ad pond yeah this
is I think we need looks like a good
move
and I'm threatening would be eight which
would really yeah really send some
confusion in to really wow mmm that
didn't expect that more
mm yeah look PA it looks like looks like
the right move for feels like the right
move maybe it isn't I can take it i mean
i'm not sure that i have half a direct
refutation
hmm okay this may be just complete crap
but just I just want to go Bishop d7 I
droopy ATM and I want to keep the spawn
and this I overlooked ah how bad is that
as simply didn't look at this move and
it's a very easy move what the heck yeah
not a move that's looking like a
complete crap often it's complete crap
it's really it this is really quite
often the case if you look if you if you
consider move and it's looking it's not
feeling right very often it isn't right
okay still still it's the position I'm
not lost or anything but Bishop see it
really was ridiculous
okay I'm attacking this Bishop and
keeping the pressure on your form you
can take here but king of eight is
basically just a double attack okay okay
to Liam or back somewhere is maybe it's
maybe we can maybe play you 50 give you
five maybe and yeah don't like it check
set up this pin down to 28 seconds how
what a shame from this great position
check-check time morning check check
check
check-check
yeah I'm not quite sure what history
maybe just trying to an on time and in
the process is so he's losing hear him
he reaches the draw but should I one on
time I cannot be no time check stalemate
yeah maybe I could've whatnot time he
was even slow at the end but I don't do
do such things wow you should see idea
what a crap move yeah I simply took got
about light c4 what a shame right here
the move that feels right is roughly 8
but I don't really want one want to give
him the spawn I mean he I think he can
really take it it's clear that I have
something I thought rook be five maybe
but the computer is showing the right
ways he fall intending Queen a7 and
Nigeria this is very strong yeah I
didn't see this idea I didn't see Queen
a seven I only thought yeah maybe I can
push c4 but i forgot about Queen a7
attacking this is the the point and this
is really at ridiculous smooth when it
still keeps keeps the edge probably the
computa actually says I'm a flat-out
winning surprisingly so I probably
played some crap crap moves afterwards
this success is winning yeah it's a
easy just attacking hand if you place me
5 i'm taking d5 this is actually what I
didn't see gay bishop c8 was ridiculous
anyway it's just a bad bad move to
retreat the route with the bishop yeah
idea I checked I started to get to get
into trouble simply so it's also because
of the time but he if he to simply began
to just change instantly without trying
to get something on the board which he I
think could have done alright thanks for
watching